well Willie you can take it from here
adios dude you'll be back You Haven't
Seen the Last of Willy is it common
knowledge that originally the
groundskeeper will if that it was
originally like a I don't know a Swedish
groundskeeper I believe Dan said can I
make it a Scottish groundskeeper because
I could get much angrier with a Scottish
voice and I believe that's how it became
groundskeeper Willie I told you you'd be
back
[Music]
hi everybody this is David Silverman
I've been on the show a very long time
he's one of the iconic directors of The
Simpsons who literally saved the day at
the very beginning of the show I'll go
along with that one and this is Matt
Selman remarkably uh creative showrunner
I'm so glad he is on our show and taking
real interesting chances not driving off
us off the cliff at all but higher near
the clinic near
[Music]
foreign
sleep tight I will mom don't let the
bedbugs bite
bed bugs we were the kind of the first
of this idea this concept of taking the
sitcom style of writing and a show with
a you know a writer's room with
animation I remember the very well Matt
coming the first day we were all happy
to meet him we loved life in hell and he
was a great guy and he went through
these sketches for the first episode
good night Simpson the first show I
directed was in fact Bart the genius
this is a big day for you why don't you
eat something a little more nutritious
not since Marge Frosty crusty flakes are
what got him where he is today it could
be one of these chemicals here that
makes him so smart I read John vd's
script and I literally thought this is
the funniest thing ever written for
animation so my first thought was like I
really have to make sure the jokes work
and present them well you know be
visually funny where I have to be but
also get out of the way of the humor and
let that really read clearly when David
was you know collaborating to create the
visual language of the show you were
thinking let's shoot this like a movie
let's make this dramatic let's put in
exciting heroic shots from other movies
like Patton and classic military dramas
like let's not just put the camera and
shoot it like a cartoon sitcom TV
animation was literally wide shot medium
shot close-up all the flat proscenium
you know no deep space shot and Wes and
I were totally like no the camera's
going to be down here it's going to be
up here it's going to be this way as
long as it works for the joke and if it
really helps uh sell the joke all the
better you know not just for the sake of
doing the cool angle the list of things
that wouldn't exist if not for that
magical lightning in a bottle of that
group of people in 1989 is a long list
it was that lightning a bottle between
the amazing riding staff that was
assembled and this new Young Scrappy
animators who wanted to prove something
or try to do something different why
wouldn't we go all in and do try to do
different things or try to be as
inventive as possible
[Music]
well usually the couch gags and
chalkboards are not connected to the
writing process of Storytelling so if
you have writers you aren't busy on any
given day we'll try to think of funny
ideas for the season ahead of time and
put those into a parallel production
process so we'll have a bunch at the
beginning of every season and then if a
show is short and we have a long couch
gag we'll use the long one if the show
is long short gag we use that one if
it's like a milestone episode like we
have our 750th episode coming up we're
trying to think of a really wamo Grand
Slam super memorable blow them away
couch gag I mean one of the ways the
show I think stays fresh now is by
bringing in outside talent to do the
couch gags for us which is also easier
for us Guillermo del Toro jaded Bill
Plimpton it really started with uh Al
getting in touch with people who did the
Banksy the storyboard came from him and
actually it was Karen Carnegie who did
that one of our retake directors the
trip it's a Belleville Animal director
you know designer animator that's one of
the highlights we ever did another other
cool thing we've done with the couch
gags is to reach out to Fan artists feel
like it's really important to embrace
people that love the show and love to
reinterpret it in their own personal
style like we had a young gentleman who
lives in Venezuela he used his designs
of the teenage version of The Simpsons
for a couch gag on an episode and I
think it connects us to a new generation
of Simpsons fans in a really special way
you know David animated a classic
Simpsons sequence of Homer eating his
way through New Orleans then these Swiss
super fans recreated it themselves
eating the food the exact food in the
exact way that David animated it and
told me how difficult it was I said well
I hadn't planned on you doing it in live
action but good for you guys they now do
couch gags for us and they've done a
couple they did one with like potato
stamps of The Simpsons they did one like
a Google doodle Janine and Katrin just
poured their passion into the show and
now they're part of our creative family
so it's amazing it's also less work for
us
[Music]
we want to do jokes about our place in
the in the real world do those jokes
about the Itchy and Scratchy Show in The
Simpsons world and Matt granning
originally parodied them after Herman
and catnip which were a more violent
version of Tom and Jerry you know the
thing about cartoon characters is they
recover from incredible pain really
quickly you know that's that's a comedy
but not Herman and katna as a kid I
watch it going like there's something
off about these cartoons my favorite
example of building pushback was not
from that but we had an episode called
the front where grandpa is fronting for
Lisa and writing episodes for a chain
scratchy and there's a shot that has
caricatures of like Jim Reardon and then
a few other animators to make Itchy and
Scratchy seem more realistic anime who
study real cats and mice and then the
Jim Reardon wouldn't puts a small
firecracker in the cat's mouth is that
real dynamite no when they go out in the
hallway Boom the door flies off the
hinges they said well you can't do that
said well we do that teaching scratchy
all the time and literally the response
was yes but those are a cartoon
[Music]
you can definitely write episodes on
secondary characters and they can be
related usually or tangentally at least
related to the family or maybe
completely related to the family but it
works very well Cletus is a Mainstay we
don't have the fetus we have one coming
up with Duff man yeah Duff man getting
his bags at the airport
mine not mine disco Stew was a great
character that came out of nowhere where
they had the rummage sale they're the
rummage sale let's do you should buy
that hey disco stew doesn't advertise a
combination of the way the character
looked and Hank is Aries hilarious voice
for it that became a regular character
we've now we've used disco stew in so
many different ways he's become part of
you know the the Mainstay of of
characters we've done that with a lot of
characters Captain McAllister Captain
we've done it with we have an episode
coming up where we get inside the heart
of Carl Carlson definitely groundskeeper
Willie if I don't save them sweet
Turtles who will
go save me from the wet Turtles the
guest actors are another like part of
the lifeblood of the show right you
might only have one shot at them like we
did a show with the weekend in season
33. I'm sorry to bother you I'm looking
for Bart Simpson he came to us he wanted
to be on the show and he said all I want
to do is I want to play one of Bart's
friends I want to play a kid the short
word Lisa and Billy eilish hang out I'm
Billy eilish you want to jam
that's it
John Lithgow just did the show recently
he was great in a parody of succession I
finally have 100 billionaire businessman
wants total revenge on the clown who
stole his dream we just had Hugh Jackman
big guest part huge singing janitor song
like half the show and our biggest
longest musical member ever yeah Bart
come with me to a magical place far in
the past America in the 20th century oh
sure but you better not start singing
Hugh Jackman was just he just says I
love singing Because yep saying this is
amazing I love singing
[Music]
that was like a very special episode
like that's the kind of thing that I
think it's important that the show is
doing now is we're really trying to be
experimental
anyone from a species that has mastered
into Galactic travel raise your hand
they are amongst the longer to produce
one of the things that is always the
case is you have three different art
directions so you have to design a lot
because you basically have to design as
much as you designed for essentially
three episodes right so for this year's
Treehouse of Horror 33 it was three you
know radically different styles the
middle section was all anime inspired by
the TV show and the manga Death Note
from Japan I am a Shinigami a god of
death in my rare I called
Steve Johnson
the show was designed and directed by
Rob Oliver the director of the episode
and David of course always makes
everything better the execution of the
animation we went to a Korean anime
house this has been one of the things
that has connected to fans like I've
never seen oh incredibly so it was a
terrific collaboration and the reaction
has been fantastic which to me wasn't a
giant surprise because I know how much
but it's a great great love for anime in
this country and it's just been growing
I'm happy to see because I've always
I've always adored anime so I knew that
was going to like hit it through the
roof
we're being sealed in a dome
well we probably started the movie in
2003 right they reassembled the dream
team of classic writers to write the
movie when they got tired I came in and
sort of watched watched the rest of it
happen you helped out where I could and
you know it really came from Jim and
Matt and Al at the time I think were the
three main creative forces I mean David
directed it and they just wanted to do a
simple story of Homer no learning not to
be selfish but play it out in this epic
grand scheme and I think it was an
amazing accomplishment how did the big
tracks get on the ceiling Spider Pig
Spider Pig does whatever a spider pig
does I was surprised by the reaction of
spider pig David was a big co-creator I
would say of the spider it literally
came up with a song off the top of my
head when we just said he could be the
Amazing Spider Pig and for some reason
that saying does whatever a spider does
I saw it you saw it I saw it happen they
had a a choir singing the monk version
of the spider pig song over the credits
of that and that was pretty cool
we had a lot of rewrites we had a lot of
false starts for one crazy weekend the
villain of the movie was Hank Scorpio
right because the villain played by
Albert Brooks he's one of the iconic
guest actors and he's played a lot of
really funny guest Parts you know the
bowling instructor first you must get to
know your lane feel this slickness feel
this set when I finish so he's the
villain originally the villain was like
a sad sack in the government who didn't
get a lot of respect he didn't seem like
a good villain because he seemed so even
when he went crazy he seemed too kind of
wimpy and Powerless and pathetic then
for one crazy weekend we said what if it
was literally Hank Scorpio from this
beloved episode you only move twice
before we continue our tour would you
mind hanging my coat up on the wall
please
um let's see um
relax Homer and Globex we don't believe
in walls matter of fact I didn't even
give you my coat
we should put out the Hank Scorpio draft
I wonder if anyone has it it was Albert
Brooks who was like oh that's a good
idea he didn't think it was a good idea
so he basically did a character like
Hank Scorpio which who wasn't Hank
Scorpio essentially because I'm a rich
man I wanted to give something back
money but something
is our chance to kick some ass for
Mother Earth it cleared a lot out of the
way we had a lot of backstory we
realized it was taking away from The
Simpsons and it's a Simpsons movie and
we want to see The Simpsons as opposed
to getting really deep into a brand new
character and these are you know
interesting lessons you learn when
making these characters into a movie
[Music]
oh almost boy that was close hey what's
up for today Neddy uh Homer we're gonna
visit the boy's grandmother
family only you know oh okay
you can't predict them you can't try to
will them into being they have to find
an audience of their own volition stupid
sexy Flanders like there are things that
I think in the show like that are kind
of meme worthy that never became memes
because you can't force virality onto a
15 second animation clip but sometimes I
mean something like that that was you
know written and it was just very funny
the animation like Homer Community out
of the bushes but in my case with Homer
skipping the land of chocolate I just
got so invested on making the skip cycle
absolutely perfect I was supervising
director at the time Mark Kirkland did
the show and he basically said I need
you to do the shot and I just kind of
kept tinkering with this until I thought
this is really funny but it is good when
you're making the show to remember that
let's do silly Flights of Fancy yeah put
in little silly side things I mean
sometimes it is easy to say oh my God we
tell this whole story in so little time
because the most important thing you
know the Jim Brooks active number one is
tell a good emotional story but you need
the little to breathe with these little
goofy asides which are those are the
things that become the memes not the
like the speech that you know touches
you but I don't know maybe we should
work harder
[Music]
there are predictions or their
suggestions and people take us up on
them yeah we're just suggesting possible
terrible thing might happen we're
probably too aware of the predictions
now because you can't try to predict
things you can what you can do is sort
of study the past and sort of see where
the mistakes Humanity has made and that
they refuse to learn from the Donald
Trump prediction joke was made in 2000
When Donald Trump was running for
president on the third party Reform
Party as you know we've inherited quite
a budget crunch from president Trump
people forget it was an easy joke to
make and then they said how did you
predict him coming down the escalator
well we didn't very smart people have
said how did you predict him coming down
the escalator right and we're like well
respectfully smart person
that was after because magic isn't real
one of the most beloved jokes in the
history of the show Homer saying oh
cartoons are stupid they don't have to
be realistic and then another Homer
walks by out the window I guess I would
say The Simpsons is proud to have been
the generational thing that three
generations of creators watched as kids
that now when they've gone in to do
their own things that's like their base
level of what create animation
creativity is so they can go and take it
in any crazy Direction they want